結構いろんな板差ってあると思うんですよ僕片頭痛を持つで頭痛も結構来られましたし
最近の動画でもずっと病院行っていますしその腹が痛くなったりをするところですよ
もちろん心が痛いときもあると思う
[音楽]
でも何より何よりはぁ彼が痛いのが一番怖いということで僕は今日削れてしまいました
初音町です今まで生きてきた中で一番
糸井って感じた5日間でした
あの最近俺どうしてるんだろうからだがもうボラっぷろ
なんか今年色々頑張ってたのもあると思うんですけどもねもう嫌
美味て打てのこのつけ麺での部分もなんかこうボロボロになってきてるんでしょ多分
疲れとストレスからそんな祭神がどうも頭痛で病院に行ったし今日に関しても母が痛く
て本当に苦しかったです
って言うかたぞいまからするよ
もし歯が痛いという人いたらちょっと一応聞いておいてください本当に人生でくっ5
日間でした
まあ様々な話をしましょうなぜ歯が痛くなったかというと虫歯じゃないですよ白じゃ
ない虫歯だったら中本ハミ受けとか言われそうなんですけども決して6スーパーでは
ありませんなんかカーチて治療していた歯があってはーちゃん物量成功してその何か
新しい箱を買ったんですけどその
歯の隙間があったみたいで普通のスキマーから5倍ちょっとがいろんなものが入って歯
の中というかそのなんか歯茎とかが炎症起こして突き突き突き突き板ってたよっていう
話でございます
松井ていいですよもうなんかなく皆さんに伝えられないのが残念なんですけどもう
めちゃくちゃ痛い神経まで注ぎ次々月9結ばよりワンちゃん僕はいたいなって思いまし
た
何だろうなあ本当につらかったですねじゃあ配信者さんといったんですよはいそれには
ちゃんと言って痛み止めをもらったんですけども痛み止めを飲んで効果が決めたため
が痛すぎるんでたミント目を止められないんですよための効果がない時は無理って
くらい痛くてねその影響であの実は昨日
動画ですでしました早すぎて無理ここらへんのた打ち回ってますて舌はって感じで
苦しくて痛み止めの食べるペースもめっちゃ早くで歯医者でもらったん量をすぐも使い
切っちゃって次の廃車まで待てないって言って実は今日
を99歯医者っていう9件で歯を診てくれる病院があったのでそこで診てもらった
ところ
ちょっとなんか本当に晴れててあお風呂場でちょっと撮ったのあるで vtr どうぞ
[音楽]
ああ
ああああああ
ブーンわー
弾力の花でとったんでこんだけね親知らずをとったわけでもなく
虫歯がある訳でもなんて言うかを抜いたわけでもなく炎症だけでここまで不満ってなっ
てそれに頭の痛みがあっていその99でしか入ったらあーこりゃもうちょっとあーっっ
夏ってちょっとグロい話になるんですけど
歯茎を切開して膿とか
性が溜まってるところを見ず打ってたから何も覚えてないんですけど僕のイメージだと
タグ木を切ってそんなが開いてこの弓とかなんかその
ドロドロの愛人とが雑菌をこっちってくれましたこれでなーん
助かったなーって思ったんですけども全然痛くて恥ずかしいんですけどハードにだった
んですよ
いや何か頭痛の動画とか出したんですけどその
7とは比べ物にならないからもいた位置にて切って中の具酒里ターンとも何か言った実
がも酷すぎて
25歳はじめシャツお恥ずかしながら歯が痛くて泣き叫んでおりました
現場のはじめさーん vtr ばぞに
walker data
んあああんでええ
macha macha
ウールクルーはあああっ
すがっん
me
ええええええ
ber
me
方がん
ん
[音楽]
はぁ
me
bebe ならくるっ
くれません
だよずば服普通
ん
me
普通ん
[音楽]
8日あーあいたくてないぞ
スゴが後ぶりですねー薬局入れます
ん
none
でしょうか秒わー
ん
ああああああ
ああああああああ
宇部ダメだダメだよねー
わかりましたどこ行ってもダメだべえん
だ
姉さん心かいいんだよ
出すいいでダメかたまんねぇ玉ただだとは釣りといると思うんですけど
便利でこんな投げるわけないでしょって言いたいがこの夫婦をペタンだけで涙となった
だったはいじゃじゃーん
ハーイ者
me
ってさぁびっくりびっくりついてるぐらいなら全然いたけどね虫歯と com 痛く
ないです
虫歯中でなくわけでのあんな次々したいたりなんかでなくわけないスポーツ違うかも
爆発順次の痛みがすごいてる
う幕営階ですけど開いてあげるいた皆絶叫2型でした
スタジオに戻ります外れ社長さあ範囲スタジオ戻ってきましたありがとうございました
これ情けないと思うでしょ無理よ僕痛みには強い方だと思ってるんですよずっついが
どんなにたい時でももレーザー立つので全然焼かれている時でももう虫歯真剣ば立派に
失われて銀
した時でも僕ないてないんですようために泣くことがないと思ってた人間がいた好き
じゃないちゃってビックリしました
付でもだが泣きながらもう本当はもうちょっと後に行く予定だった
元々入ってた会社に電話するとあ今日行けますよって言ってもらえて
ハグ give してきて講義って食らってトッター桑の葉はそのままもう一個病院
行って来い
をな風味が出やすいように今回はちゃんと新しくできた歯を抜いて今第二痛みが治まっ
ているという感じです
今のだいぶほっぺが腫れてるんですけどはいというわけですいませんなんかツイッター
で結構やばいやばいって叫んじゃったんですけど
前世で一番痛い5日間でございますいやーもうなんかねー
最近混ぜ体のボロが来てんだよなぁやば忙しいんですけどもうちょっと自分の身の回り
のことに時間を使った方がいいのかなとか思った25歳のはじめしゃちょーでした虫歯
じゃないけどやっぱちゃんとに歯医者には行きみっかなと思ったけど実際歯医者行く
時間ないんだろうな
皆さんには伝えておきは葉が一番言いたい入った
たで25歳をどこがなくってじゃあ怖いなって思いましたね結ばのした後の歯の羅列に
なってくるに気づかされてしまいましたみんな
歯医者に行こうぜ
[音楽]
me
ran